Starting with mean and
standard deviation.
We call the function mean and
std on our dataframe to get the values.
Let's go ahead and check the mean and
the standard deviation for
the daily returns of SPY stock.
So we get the mean and
the standard deviation.
Happy with just knowing the mean and
standard deviation value?
But I am not.
I want to see it on the plot,
just like Professor did.
So let's learn how to add mean and
standard deviation line on plot.
Matplotlib library has
a function axvline.
Looking at the substring vline,
we can guess it will give vertical line.
Let's check out its parameters.
First we pass the mean value,
then just for beautification and so
that we can differentiate the mean line
from the rest histogram, we add a color,
which is white, make it a dashed style
line and increase the linewidth to two.
Now let's check our output.
So this our mean and this is how
it is plotted on the histogram.
Now let's go ahead and
plot standard deviation.
To plot the standard deviation line,
it is similar to the mean.
But as we want the standard deviation
line on both side of the mean,
we plot it twice.
One with the positive value and
one with the negative value,
to show standard deviation line
on either side of the mean.
Ta dah, we have our standard
deviation lines on our graph.
To give the standard
deviation a red color,
I have just replaced the parameter
color of white, with red.
Now I'm happy with the graph and
I hope you do are.
Let's move ahead to kurtosis.
We can expect that dataframe
would have a function for
calculating kurtosis as well.
So that's it.
This line will give you
kurtosis of the daily returns.
We get a positive value for the SPY
stock, which means we have fat tails.
Just for your information,
you can also get bincounts
using numpy.histogram function.
Check instructors notes for
more information.
Over to you professor.